how well everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast modern pain management
medications in pregnancy and in neonate
presented by Blinn Macmillan PhD medical
director toxicology and pharmacogenetics
a RUP laboratory I in Cristina Mahalo to
levers and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by Lavery's lab earth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem
this presentation is educational center
offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
obtain your credit now please join me in
welcoming dr. McMillan I will now turn
the presentation over to her dr.
McMillan before is yours well
and thank you for joining me so as
mentioned I'm going to be talking about
monitoring pain management medications
in pregnancy and the neonate which is
important because pregnancy is not
exempt from both medical and social
needs related to the management of acute
pain chronic pain substance use
disorders and addiction for a woman that
is interested in becoming pregnant and
also is being treated for chronic pain
it's important to offer preconception
counseling to discuss therapeutic
options both pharmacological and
non-pharmacological in the United States
it's estimated by the opioid
prescription claims survey that 14
percent of women receive at least one
dose of an opioid during their pregnancy
and it might be surprising to know that
opioid misuse and abuse during pregnancy
has increased in fact women now receive
more opioid prescriptions than men and
heroin Ruth heroin youth has increased a
hundred percent among women between the
years of 2002 and 2013 compared with a
50 percent increase among men and in
fact every three minutes it's estimated
that a woman seeks emergency care
related to prescription opioid misuse
and deaths from prescription among women
have increased more than 400% between
the years of 1999 and 2010 compared with
237 percent increase in men so chronic
opioid use is a problem for women in
pregnancy there are many many concerns
including acute withdrawal which could
increase the risk of miscarriage
placental abruption low birth weight
preterm labor and still birth but we
we'd recognize that there are some pain
conditions that respond best to
therapy so opioids may be indicated and
if so they need to be titrated to
provide adequate therapeutic response
and also prevent acute withdrawal in
cases of addiction considering opioid
substitution with drugs such as
methadone or buprenorphine is
appropriate and these drugs have been
shown to help decrease high risk
maternal activities reduce exposure to
the unborn child and reduce the risks of
withdrawal symptoms in both mother and
the infant when we talk about
withdrawals observed in the infant we're
characteristically talking about
neonatal abstinence syndrome or na s
nationally the CDC has reported that in
2012 approximately one infant with NIS
was born every 25 minutes in their
morbidity and mortality weekly report
that was published in August of 2016
they reported data for 28 States for
which the incidence of na s was publicly
available and that a schematic of that
data is shown on the next slide so you
can see that the geographical
variability is pretty intense the states
where that have experienced some of the
most dramatic increases in the incidence
of NIS include Vermont Virginia and
Maine overall the incidence has
increased over 300 percent since 1999 so
as a consequence several health systems
are now developing programs for pregnant
women with opioid substance abuse
problems or addiction to offer programs
that provide comprehensive support for
managing opioid addiction with the hope
to reduce the overall incidence of Naas
some programs attempt to wean the mother
off of of medications that the
detoxification process can cause extreme
stress to both the mother and the fetus
and is associated with high rates of
relay
as such the medication-assisted
management or opioid substitution
primarily with methadone and
buprenorphine is recommended so this
slides references the executive summary
of a recent joint workshop on opioid use
and pregnancy where opioid substitution
was extensively discussed and the
reference is on this slide so you can
see methadone and buprenorphine are
compared and methadone is the historical
drug has been used for opioid addiction
since 1974 and has been demonstrated to
reduce cravings and prevent illicit use
of opioids like heroin methadone
programs are either outpatient or
inpatient that they're much more
intensive than buprenorphine programs
which are entirely outpatient so
methadone programs tend to be more
successful than buprenorphine at
managing poly substance abuse
buprenorphine is a newer drug approved
by the FDA in 2002 for opioid
substitution and as suggested the major
advantage of you preneur Fein is that it
can be self administered which makes
treatment much more mobile and
convenient but also makes diversion a
concern the safety profile for
buprenorphine is also favored over
methadone however compliance is less
successful leading to higher rates of
relapse the overall incidence of Naas in
both methadone and buprenorphine exposed
infants is approximately the same that
is much less than what's been observed
in heroin exposed infants
is treated well historically it's been
treated many ways that primarily with
administration of morphine to console
the child and other medications to
support other needs and then those drugs
are slowly weaned and as you can see the
historical average length of hospital
stay for these babies has been 23 days
with cost the hospital approaching a
hundred thousand dollars per infant and
much of that is built to Medicaid so
this represents a huge burden on the
healthcare system and outside of the
medical costs we have to consider the
social costs endured by the mother the
infant and the family so there's been
some new approaches to treating na s
being very sensitive to these both
medical and social costs where we're
adopting essentially a mantra of hugs
before drugs and also known as eat sleep
and console and so just as an example of
a success story
the Yale New Haven Children's Hospital
recently did a pilot study that was
published and here they found tremendous
success by reducing the average length
of stay from twenty two point four days
to five point nine days and the
percentage of infant's treated with
morphine from 98% to 14% which also of
course reduces the overall incidence
overall costs all the way around similar
approaches are now being implemented
across the u.s. us which I think will
bring a significant positive future to
everyone involved in managing opioid
addiction and pregnancy and na s so the
American College of obstetrics and
Gynecologists reports that more than
eighty six percent of pregnancies
conceived by women with opioid use
disorders are unplanned and so pregnancy
is actually a great and unique
opportunity to help intervene
by offering non-judgmental assistance
and acknowledging that these opioid use
disorders are medical conditions
pregnancy becomes the opportunity to
provide care that is needed for both
managing the pregnancy and the opioid
use disorder and in doing so we can help
women become healthy confident loving
and effective mothers so how can we help
it's been proposed that all women who
are pregnant be screened for drugs and
that's because of the conception that
drug testing is an objective tool I put
on the slides sort of because we know
that self-reported drug use is very poor
and we also know that understanding of
the nuances of drug testing is
relatively poor so providers may not
know what drug tests to order and how to
interpret it we may have issues with
maternal consent and while patient
provider agreements are common in a pain
management setting they're not common in
a typical non pain management or non
opioid addiction setting so as such drug
tests are most commonly just utilized
today in treating in women that are
being treated for opioid addiction and
chronic pain in the future I think it
would make sense to reconsider and
either universal test or to consider the
outcome of psychosocial and physical
exams testing at least the first print
prenatal visit and at delivery
potentially some time in between just to
make sure that baby and mom are safe
so as suggested earlier an intensive
approach to treating and monitoring
women who receive chronic pain therapy
or medication assisted therapy for
opioid use disorders can't improve fetal
outcomes and reduce treatment duration
and so there's some data to support that
here monitoring is very very helpful in
assuring compliance with therapy
particularly for buprenorphine
but in addition to drug testing we need
to include a very much a comprehensive
approach where the mother receives
appropriate prenatal care chemical
dependency counseling nutritional
education medical and psychosocial
support and so forth so monitoring is is
a big-picture approach not just about
lab testing but let's go ahead and talk
about lab testing there are several
things to think about when initiating a
test and one of the biggest concerns is
how to assure that all drugs except an
infant may be exposed to are detected
and I'm here to tell you that that
expectation is unrealistic detection
requires understanding of the many
variables associated with drug detection
and those reflect the quality of the
specimen the timing of when the specimen
was collected relative to the last use
of a drug overall drug use patterns the
specific drug and how the patient
handles it technology is used for
testing the assay design itself
performance of that assay cutoff
concentrations and other variables of
assay performance so just to illustrate
with these two bars it is possible that
we have two specimens containing drugs
at different concentrations but based on
a cut-off threshold only one would be
the green one in this case would be
reported as positive so these false
negatives are a major concern for take
with random specimens or specimens that
are a for quality or when the assay
specifications don't meet the
expectations so in terms of analytical
technologies there's really two primary
technologies used in drug testing and
those are immunoassays or mass
spectrometric assays so immunoassays are
based on monoclonal or poly polyclonal
antibodies that have affinity for a
specific chemical structure the
specificity does vary with si to assay
manufacturer to manufacture some are
designed to detect several chemically
similar similar drugs such as a class of
benzodiazepines or opioids and others
are detected or designed to detect a
very very specific compound such as
oxycodone in any case si performance as
I mentioned will vary between specific
products and it's important to consult
pashka package inserts or labeling that
come with the assay reagents to define
and understand cross reactivity profiles
for the assay which will help provide
clues regarding the possibility of false
positive or false negative results the
mass spectrometric assays detect drugs
and metabolites through specific ions or
combinations of ions that result from
fragmentation of a drug molecule the
common technologies are coupled with gas
or liquid chromatography and so you may
recognize acronyms like GCMs or a gas
chromatography with mass spectrometric
detection or LC ms/ms which is liquid
chromatography with tandem mass
spectrometry or triple quad technology
and those aren't the only ones because
those are the most common technologies
in place today
these technologies because of the
specificity of the mass spectrometer are
considered confirmatory or definitive
and may be designed to generate either
qualitative or quantitative
results however the actual quality of
the results and likelihood of true
positive results is dependent on the
assay design and specific performance
characteristics of that assay so it's
important to consult with your
laboratory to understand the strengths
and limitations of drug approaches drug
testing approaches and and what would be
the best approach for you in terms of
specimens there are a lot of specimens
that have been evaluated for detecting
in utero drug exposure and as listed
those here they essentially reflect
different times of drug exposure during
a pregnancy some specimens are unique to
the fetus or infant which can provide
clear evidence of a drug exposure when
results are positive so this tend to be
the most desirable surprisingly a
positive maternal specimen demonstrates
that the mother was exposed to the drug
that does not necessarily prove that the
fetus or infant was exposed so the fetal
and neonatal specimens are generally
preferred and so I'll just run through
some of the pros and cons of these based
on the temporal time that the detection
time anticipated for these specimens so
when we think about oral fluid or blood
we're thinking of detection within hours
- potentially days that short-term
detection so so this is only going to
reflect very recent drug use now that
could be very useful for monitoring
maternal drug use during pregnancy
because testing could be performed
weekly for example but with a newborn
we're not going to be able to collect
oral fluid or blood until birth and
there's limited specimen that's
available and that short time frame is
not terribly useful so these are not
commonly used for for newborns in terms
of medium-term detection specimens urine
is the most commonly utilized
that's what amniotic fluid vernix and
placenta has been evaluated
in adults we recognize urine as the most
common and best understood specimen but
as the pictured specimen bag suggests
collection of urine from a neonate is
challenging and is not the preferred
specimen because the first void after
birth which is going to reflect the
longest period of time is easily missed
as infants may actually avoid during
delivery or shortly thereafter and so so
the specimen is unavailable
there's also analytical concerns because
some topical soaps have been shown to
contaminate neonatal urine leading to
false positive immunoassays and there
has also been studies that have shown
some drug metabolites are different in
infants than in adults and so typical
assays and this has been demonstrated
specifically for cannabis or THC are
different and so you may get a positive
screen with an immunoassay that unable
to confirm that result with a standard
mass spectrometric method the placenta
has been studied primarily in research
purposes or research settings as you
probably recognize it's a vascular organ
that's responsible for maternal fetal
exchange and and and so is a sink for
drugs the quantitative analysis of
methadone and buprenorphine in placenta
has actually been correlated with
severity and duration of na s but the
detection window is quite brief
reflecting only about one week of
exposure and the logistics of collection
testing are really not very well
characterized sweat amniotic fluid and
vernix are also used in research
settings that detection limit is
reflecting one week or less and routine
specimen collection methods and testing
approaches are not widely available
so that leads us to long-term detection
specimens which are the most desirable
because of reflecting weeks to months of
drug activity prior to delivery for all
these specimens there are concerns about
risks of external contamination what the
appropriate or predominant analyte would
be in each of these specimens and the
appropriate cut-offs
there's really no standardized methods
and so there is variation from lab to
lab hair neonatal hair typically forms
at about 20 weeks of gestation and
reaches the scalp about three weeks
later and has historically been used but
has become relatively controversial
because not all neonates are born with
hair shaving or cutting the hair can be
culturally offensive and we also don't
necessarily understand the mechanism of
drug incorporation into hair so the the
specimen of choice really has been
meconium neonatal nails has been
challenging because there's inadequate
specimen and then available court issue
is is a newer specimen that is starting
to gain traction and become preferred by
many organizations and so I'll focus on
meconium and umbilical cord is they
really are most commonly used today
so meconium is you're not aware is the
first stool of the newborn it's a black
tarry substance and it's very
distinctive from milk stool it may pass
within a few hours of birth or it may
take a few days that usually passes
within about 48 hours and it may require
several different collections so this
means scraping diapers and consolidating
those samples which can logistical ii
become problematic and in fact mothers
that know they're being watched may
actually intervene and steal the
meconium discarding it the detection of
drugs depends on many many factors
including quality and complete list of
that connection collection drug use
patterns and the gestation of the of the
baby so we know that that meconium
begins to form between 12th and 16th
week but it accumulates over the
remainder of the pregnancy but that
that's a nonlinear process and the
actual deposition will vary umbilical
chord forms earlier about the fifth week
of gestation but it also grows in a
nonlinear process and so the bulk of the
tissue is represented in the third
trimester and so detection does tend to
reflect primarily the last trimester of
a full-term birth we know that drugs
appear to deposit quite consistently
across the length of the cord such that
you can collect the cord at the time of
birth and just send to the lab a portion
of it so this either collection has been
the major reason why umbilical cord has
has gained some interest and is growing
in popularity so essentially every child
has one you can collect it right at
birth and we do know that the
concentrations of drug analytes in cord
are much lower than meconium which means
we have to adjust our methods to
accommodate that so we may be looking at
things in a picogram per gram range
whereas meconium would be in the the
nanogram per gram range so the assays
are evolving over time to improve
detection the actual analytes of
interest may also be different and so
assays again are evolving to reflect the
best possible detection approach for
these specimen types so based on what we
know today the major advantages of the
two specimens are summarized on this
slide with meconium we've got more drug
there so it's easier to find there's
absolutely no debate about the child
being exposed because
the meconium is inside the child and
there's a substantial amount of research
to support interpretation with the cord
as I mentioned all infants have one and
there's plenty of specimens that can be
sent to the lab right at birth which
facilitates time to result which is very
desirable because infants that are
released to the hospital before the
symptoms of NIS appear may be lost to
follow-up it may not get the care that
they need another advantage of cord is
that it avoids detection of drugs that
are administered directly to the infant
after birth and we have found that that
cord results tend to be less discrepant
in twins and triplets than meconium and
that's really because of the logistics
of collection where you get the cord
right at birth for as the meconium comes
when it comes and so in a multiple birth
situation the collection may be better
for one twin or one one of the children
then than the others some of the the
disadvantage of the specimens as I
mentioned collection is the major
disadvantage for meconium and also
specimen availability with cord we know
that we may not be as sensitive for all
drugs and that's really a reflection of
understanding what concentrations we
need to be at to accurately detect drugs
of interest both specimens suffer from
heterogeneity particularly with
premature births they both suffer from
risk of contamination with meconium you
can get contamination from the infant
urine and with the cord you can get
contamination from the maternal blood so
those are risks that have to be accepted
we also know that no lab test is perfect
and some negative results do not exclude
the possibility of exposure and though
there's no standardized methods or
cut-offs so knowing that tests are now
available
not standardized the question arises as
to whether this kind of testing is
mandated in the US and the answer is no
although the the 2010 child abuse
prevention treatment act or CAPTA does
provide federal funds to States to help
support investigation which could
include laboratory testing and the 2015
protecting our infants acts requires the
Department of Health and Human Services
to review the activities around prenatal
opioid use including the incidence of na
s which is part of the reason that we
have some nice data coming out now
deciding who how and what to test is
another issue what we know is the
testing criteria need to be unbiased as
much as possible there needs to be a
cause to test or universal testing
Universal testing is not common right
now that instead most facilities will
first of all consider their local or
state policies and then evaluate risk of
exposure so evaluating risk requires
establishing questionnaires or criteria
regarding prenatal care or the
presentation of the mother or the child
and and then collecting specimens now
some facilities are collecting specimens
from all births and only submitting the
specimens that reach the high-risk
category then storing low-risk category
specimens until the baby has been
monitored for signs of symptoms of na s
or other concerns that may make it
appropriate to pursue testing so what
are some of those risk factors this is a
list of some examples of risk factors
related to mother and newborn so there
they're actually quite logical
others who have a history of drug user
abuse and a known at-risk environment a
history of high risk behavior like
prostitution mothers who present with
placental abruption or unexplained
premature labor and teenage moms have
historically been at higher risk also
newborns that present with unexplained
neurological complications that are very
small at the time of birth or have signs
and symptoms of na s also fall in that
category but this list is associated
with fairly limited experience from the
University of Iowa that they've
published recently to evaluate the
diagnostic yield of these misc factors
and so they did a retrospective analysis
of their practices and an extensive
chart review for all positive drug tests
and this included meconium and urine
samples and what they found is
essentially no utility of urine very low
positivity rates but a very good utility
of the meconium wherein almost 70% of
positive results could be explained by a
just maternal history of non-medical
drugs fifty-one percent could be
explained by maternal history of tobacco
use and so when you combine those two
risk factors you could actually explain
almost 91% of the positive samples
meaning that a lot of the other risk
factors didn't have a very strong
diagnostic yield
to have results it's important to
evaluate those results relative to
pretest expectations so are you
expecting a particular drug yes and you
got a positive results then all is good
proceed with your local policies and
procedures if you've got an inconsistent
results meaning and unexpected or an
unexpected positive result then it's
encouraged that you consult pharmacy
records discuss the testing and
associated results at the laboratory and
also approach the mother to help
reconcile those results so some of the
the common questions that that I've seen
relative to interpretation of results
are can try mister first trimester
exposures be detected and the answer is
no and that's related very much to this
nonlinear process of specimen
accumulation and so there's a strong
dilution effect of anything that
happened in the first trimester or there
wasn't any real specimen there to begin
with our drugs administered during labor
and delivery detected and the answer to
that is also yes does and that's
reflected actually by data on this slide
where we had a history of maternal
prescription for morphine as well as a
known infant prescription and we saw
positive results for morphine as well as
hydromorphone winces can be a minor
metabolite of morphine hydrocodone is
probably unrelated but in any case yes
drugs administered during labor and
delivery can not always that can be
detected in meconium or in available
court issue regarding the next questions
common questions which I know you can't
see right now but related to whether the
source drug
can be determined and whether a negative
result indicates the drugs weren't used
to study that we looked at
concentrations of morphine and common
related opioids six mono acid til
morphine which is a metabolite of heroin
hydrocodone hydromorphone and coding and
so this question comes up quite a bit
about heroin detection where our mother
has admitted to heroin use and the lab
doesn't find the six am metabolite and
so what we did with the the data on this
slide is look at results from about
seventy five thousand patients and
analyzed the patterns of when we
observed six am and so when we observe
six am we see morphine concentrations
that are very very high
we also see hydrocodone that's quite low
and then hydromorphone which again is a
minor metabolite of morphine and codeine
which is a an impurity of heroin and so
this is a typical pattern that is
observed even in the absence of a six
and can provide supporting evidence for
use of morphine or use of heroin when
that six a metabolite is not found so in
thinking about why six am isn't often
detected we also performed a stability
test for six am and what we found is
that six am is relatively unstable and
so within two weeks of spiking we lose
about 50% considering that the general
concentration is around eleven nanograms
per gram which is often close to a
cut-off of 10 nanograms per gram it's
it's very likely that that six am will
be missed by mo
laboratory tests and that is evidenced
also by their the rare positivity rates
that have been seen so it suggests that
we need to do something different with
our tests and that may be increasing the
sensitivity of the test lowering those
cut-offs so that we can capture it using
other biomarkers of heroin use perhaps
using different specimens and one of the
other things that that relates to this
is questions about synthetic opioids
such as fentanyl analogues and and pink
or you for 7700 which are now being used
in many places around the country often
as heroin substitutes that are not
picked up so we have babies that are
presented with na s and we don't find
any drugs to really explain that which
can be very frustrating this slide
addresses one of the other questions
relative to the content so cut off
concentration is important in this data
set there were authentic samples that
were positive for cannabis or THC using
an immunoassay that had a cut-off of one
nanogram per gram we then analyzed and
by a mass spectrometric method that
looks at four different analytes of
cannabis so the parent THC the two
metabolites eleven hydroxy and nine
carboxy and then a cannabinol and what
we found is that the there was one
sample that was positive for Eliza but
actually didn't contain any of the
traditional analytes instead cañedo
contained only cannabinol which is not
thought to be psychoactive and so might
lead to inappropriate interpretations we
also saw a number of samples that were
positive by this mass spec method but
were negative by this is an example here
negative by the Eliza but positive by
the mass spectrometric method so the
take-home message is that content and
cutoff concentrations can make a big
difference in terms of positivity and
getting a negative result doesn't
necessarily mean that there were there
was no drug exposure so now I'll show
you a little bit of data from
laboratories that have converted from
meconium d'accord
or at least considered it with an
evaluation of the two specimen types
head-to-head and so this also comes from
the University of Iowa where they
actually saw a very similar positivity
rates for the two specimens but they
notably found that the the distribution
of positive results was different in the
courts and the meconium to where the
chords actually seem to be more
sensitive to oxycodone than the meconium
and the meconium was picking up a number
of the medications that are administered
directly to the newborn such as codeine
morphine lorazepam and phenobarbital so
this actually really confounds the
interpretation of the results because
you don't know for sure whether the baby
received these drugs and that explains
the result or if the mom received the
drugs in addition to baby receiving drug
here
from Vanderbilt University they
published a parrot result study for
court and meconium where they found in
217 newborns that there were 114
discordant results and so what I want to
highlight is that sometimes the court is
positive
sometimes the meconium is positive
sometimes both are positive but for
different analytes and so the specimens
even though they both are thought to
reflect drug use during the last
trimester do have differences in terms
of sensitivity and at the laboratory
methods are going to contribute to that
as well so in the case of Vanderbilt
they concluded that the court collection
was logistically preferred but that they
did not choose to switch and stuck with
their meconium which they were more
comfortable with here a study that was
recently published from Ohio State
University showed very good negative
agreement and mixed positive agreement
what they what I think was most notable
is that they found their clinical
sensitivity for Naas was improved with
court but that there were still a number
of babies with Naas diagnoses for which
both meconium and cord results were
negative so in their in their case they
chose to to switch to court because of
the logistics that they also recognize
that not everything is going to be
detected and that we still have room for
improvement in monitoring these babies
so this risk of false negatives is the
biggest concern and so it's important to
consider the specimen quality the drug
use patterns the stability of the drug
analytes and the performance
capabilities of the assays when
interpreting results
so regardless of drug drug testing
results you don't treat the result you
treat the patient and neonates with then
I ask need to be monitored after birth
to minimize the likelihood of long-term
consequences such as those shown on this
slide and mothers also need to be
monitored unfortunately it's been shown
that that discontinuation of opioid
substitution therapy and relapse is
relatively common within the first six
months of birth so maternal urine drug
testing is recommended to assure
adherence to the opioid substitution
plan and abstinence from non prescribed
drugs adequate pediatric care is also
very important to monitor and and it's
time to have that discussion about
whether or not to breastfeed in general
breastfeeding is encouraged for mothers
that are adherent with methadone and
buprenorphine therapy because there's
very little of those drugs that appears
to get into the breast milk but concerns
may arise regarding other drugs
especially used to illicit and non
prescribed drugs chronic alcohol use or
other indicators of aberrant drug use
fortunately there are guidelines about
breastfeeding this 2015 guideline makes
recommendations specific to individual
drugs and promotes the use of
breastfeeding for babies that are
exposed to methadone or buprenorphine or
mothers that are treated with those
drugs whereas the mothers that are known
to use cannabis or THC containing
products are discouraged from
breastfeeding because the THC tends to
concentrate in the the breast milk
itself so this seems like a
contradictory statement some drugs are
okay some drugs are not okay
and in fact these guidelines are based
on extensive research to understand how
drugs are transferred into the milk and
with what efficiency we know that some
drugs are trapped in a breast milk due
to the pka or chemistry of the drug
binding of the drugs to proteins or
lipids
in the breast milk we're also aware of
changes in drug transporters that can
influence transfer of drugs into the
milk there's been enthusiasm to measure
milk plasma ratios and in particular a
cc's or area under the curve but we now
know that drug concentrations in milk do
not change in parallel with drug
concentrations in plasma and
pharmacokinetic model lists have been
developed to incorporate everything we
can know about that drug transfer into
the breast milk to evaluate the
appropriateness of breastfeeding in that
for that infant what we have to remember
is it's not just about how much gets
into the milk but about how much milk
the baby drinks and what the size of the
baby is and so what's one of the things
that's been interesting is that it's
been demonstrated that accumulation of
drugs is more relevant than an
occasional use of drugs such as say a
course of antibiotics
so I encourage you to consult the
Academy of breastfeeding medicine
guidelines as well as this very
informative and easy-to-use website
called lactMed which is a drugs and
lactation database hosted by the US
National Library of Medicine and it's
peer reviewed and updated monthly it
provides references for all of its
recommendations it provides information
on the concentration of drugs and drug
metabolites that are anticipated in the
breast milk possible adverse effects of
Nursing as well as therapeutic
alternatives for for drugs of specific
indications so it's a great resource so
with that I come to my conclusion slide
and so pain management is important in
pregnancy because pain may actually
intensify with pregnancy and we need to
treat the patient we need to manage that
pain prevent withdrawal when there's
suspicion of addiction and consider the
impact of drug therapy on the fetus as
well as the subsequently on the infant
urine drug testing is an important tool
for monitoring drug adherence during
pregnancy and lactation whereas meconium
and umbilical cord are the preferred
specimens although not perfect and they
are the preferred specimens for
evaluating drug adherence it with
buprenorphine and methadone as well as
for detecting use of non prescribed or
illicit drugs the drug testing results
have to be interpreted based on the
maternal and infant history as well as
strengths and limitations of the
associated specimens and the analytical
methods so thank you for your attention
thank you dr. McMillan for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started with our first
question
our first question asks is it
recommended that breast milk completely
- we routinely tested for drugs so there
are not any specific guidelines related
to testing breast milk there are
laboratories that offer breast milk
testing and if there's a good reason to
test the breast milk such as a serious
and suspected exposure it may be
appropriate
however breast milk represents only a
few hours since drug exposure for most
drugs and so it will really only reflect
very recent or daily cues of drugs
breast milk is also challenging and that
the concentrations of the drugs may be
different in the for milk kind milk and
other portions of a feeding so if one is
going to test breast milk the preferred
approach would be to collect an entire
feeding and mix that and then send that
in for testing relative to
interpretation as I mentioned earlier
you need to really think about how much
milk the infant consumes relative to the
infant's weight when looking at the
concentrations so interpretation is is
really challenging and I wouldn't really
recommend thank you for your answer our
second question asks when is chain of
custody required for drug testing so
chain of custody is a forensic or legal
document that authenticates every step
of the process from specimen collection
to destruction and so it's very
important to use a chain of custody if a
result is going to be admitted as
evidence in a criminal court system or
other forensic proceedings for most of
the testing
associated with detecting in utero
exposure forensic processing is not
required because the purpose of testing
you know that the whole reason is is
medically based to manage the patient
treat the patient provide the care
necessary for the mother and the infant
sometimes medical testing results are
utilized for sayed child custody
scenarios which are usually heard in a
civil court system and in my experience
chain of custody is not routinely
required as long as the policies and
procedures that the hospital EMA
laboratory have for specimen collection
handling and testing are followed thank
you
the next question asks should drugs
other than opioids be included in a drug
test intended for chronic pain patient
so opioids have gotten most of the
attention and that's likely because of
the opioid epidemic that we've seen in
our population in general which has now
led into the pregnant population and the
association of opioids with dnas however
other drugs are important to other drugs
can contribute to the the onset and
severity as well as duration of Naas and
so it is practical to test for other
drugs it's not feasible for most labs to
look for any possible drug drug and
there really aren't any guidelines to to
dictate the content of an assay so most
laboratories choose to offer panels that
include opioids sedatives like
benzodiazepines and barbiturates
stimulants like amphetamines and cocaine
and cannabis to cover commonly
controlled prescribed and illicit
medication thank you for your
sir we have another question this one
asks what testing is available to detect
the various classes of designer drugs on
the street or available through the
internet so that's a good question is we
have seen an infiltration of synthetic
opioids synthetic stimulants synthetic
cannabis lots of synthetic or designer
drugs are now on the street and widely
available on the Internet in some cases
an immunoassay such as one performed in
a hospital laboratory will cross-react
with the synthetic drug leading to a
positive result that can help guide care
of the patient but in most cases the
synthetic analogues are undetected by
the traditional testing and in fact most
of emergency rooms are going to to treat
the the patient not the test results so
so unfortunately they're not easy ways
to look for all of these designer drugs
there are specialty toxicology
laboratories that are probably there
your best bet at identifying those
unique drug compounds okay thank you for
your answer we have time for one more
question today and the final question
asks is it appropriate for a clinic to
perform urine urine drug testing with
the home tests or otherwise commercially
available dipstick
or cops yeah so you may have noticed
tips that you can purchase either at
local drug stores grocery stores and on
the internet that that are promoted for
home testing similar products for
testing that are either essentially
urine collection cups that are embedded
with immunoassay strips or dipsticks
themselves are
available for purchase in bulk that that
are very very tempting to clinics
because they're affordable and you get a
result very very quickly but I would
caution any clinic that's considering
these types of tests to read the
labeling and understand the regulatory
implications of that kind of testing
testing is classified in the US based on
complexity which influences your
regulatory requirements for the the
people that perform the tests for the
licensure of the clinic itself and for
any subsequent testing so if the test is
considered waived which mean that it's
of the simplest complexity and appears
to be a exempt from a lot of the CLIA or
other related regulations be cautious
and look at that labeling because most
of those labels require that any
positive result be confirmed by a GCMs
or LC ms/ms type methods which could
lead to pretty expensive consequences if
the likelihood of positive results is
high which it usually is in chronic pain
patients so so it may not be appropriate
and I think I would caution you to look
at the details that are associated with
any test that's implemented in a clinic
setting before we're pursuing it and
subsequently billing for it
thank you dr. McMillan for your time and
for your presentation I would also like
to thank Lavery's for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February of
2018 you will receive an email from
lathers letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again here soon at lab
goodbye